first of all as we've heard the subjects
were subjected to these various
techniques not just at guantanamo bay
for example but the report will also
have looked at other locations secret
cia prisons that were being run in in
thailand for example so the focus of
report is worldwide potentially isn't it
that's right there seems to be a number
of facilities which the uh report does
not identify by country but probably at
least four or five um where where some
of these techniques may have been used
as well as a network of other facilities
where detainees were transited through
and held for periods of time on the way
to then being taken to these cia run
facilities where these enhanced
interrogation techniques as they called
them uh were visited upon people and now
we have the detailed information about
what that meant well that's right and
that detail being out in the open now
will prompt some to worry about
the threat to american interests and i
guess
one of the areas that u.s officials are
most concerned about is africa and the
middle east absolutely i mean clearly
american uh air power is being used in
iraq and syria um there are no longer
ground forces in iraq and certainly none
in syria but the americans and the
british are still withdrawing out of
afghanistan some of the detainees were
certainly captured uh in pakistan or
afghanistan well weren't necessarily
nationals of those countries some were
again there's they're not very clear
about the nationalities of all the
people although over the last 10 years
we've learned about many of the people
uh who were subjected to the to these
techniques so i think certainly us
interests in in certain parts of the
world uh won't be helped by by the
admission um albeit belated that these
things happened well
of course is that uh this is a democracy
in action which is going through this in
in forensic detail and developing a
public debate in america and and this
should should reassure some countries
that the americans
are addressing it well that's right you
mentioned afghanistan of course the
americans with its allies went into iraq
as well and we heard all about what went
on at abu ghraib prison and this is an
area that's deeply unstable as well at
the moment as well isn't that that's
right and the worrying thing about abu
ghraib was that this was not a cia-run
facility but one run by the department
of defense by the military the us
military in iraq but it seems that some
of these techniques that were approved
for use against
the highest value al-qaeda targets in
2002 2003 these techniques were then
exported to
the uh campaign in iraq which is not
what they were designed to do in the
first place and then we ended up with
those
well-known photographs of mistreatment
so what can we expect the americans to
do to beef up if you like their security
i mean what about it close to our home
at the moment in europe for example
i think for the next few days certainly
uh u.s embassy in consular facilities
will probably be on a heightened state
of alert um they'll be watching out for
um whether demonstrations might take
place
however this is necessarily historical
uh the these events and and this this
program was closed down in 2006 uh
admitted to and in fact the cia released
all all of its detainees detainees or
moved them to other facilities okay so
marines in europe and also in the middle
east as well likely to be on on high
alert you imagine yes and obviously
there are us forces in many parts of the
world with communities
who may use this as an excuse to vent
their frustration
but having said that the major threat to
some extent at the moment still comes
from isil uh and and their campaign
against um in the in the main uh in
innocent hostages um um who uh
you know might be a greater threat at
the moment um as as they seek to as you
know uh execute people wearing orange
jumpsuits with with the with the
suggestion that this is because of
guantanamo of course it's much more
complex than that